yeah welcome to this video playing white
against Lord Jim from the Netherlands
and I don't know who that is it's got a
name in there others is jaron bush he's
down author and mastermind of this very
well known SOS seriously some secrets of
opening surprises and he's going for the
old Indian so good to good international
must I played him in a tournament game
actually and some know about 10 years
ago and he's some pretty successful play
also in the Dutch league and a Dutch
open tournaments okay the old Indian the
old engine is somewhat similar to the
Kings Indian but black hasn't played g6
but played with Bishop to e7 um I played
them the classical set up again this
simply because I don't know any other
it's um it's leading to the typical kind
of space advantage positions where wide
always enjoys a bit of a pool but it's
not overwhelming a5 yeah it's not easy
to learn to determine the best um
structure for black a five or a six it's
not not easy to to say so how should I
continue now I can play 91 centers night
back then night to d3 not sure if this
is a good setup this also neglects this
Bishop g5 possibility not sure if I
should down
move the night
but also i'm not quite positive if i
should go for B form in this position
hmm
hmm difficult
difficult position yeah this was to be
expected I thought I didn't think that
the f5 would be a much of an issue maybe
I miss misjudged dead it's maybe
possible that he plays at five now
the kind of active move you like to play
in a blitz game maybe it's not one
hundred percent sound but it's it's
active at least okay so should produce
seven yeah my intention of course was to
learn to prepare a three and before but
this effin with f5 farm maneuver
irritates me maybe I really should turn
sent the night back 91 but I don't like
it okay I need to move cannot spend much
more time yeah
yeah this is probably a very comfortable
position for black he's got b5 now hmm
exactly
I Boyd I've got before now before wed I
didn't didn't think about this
beforehand before yeah this is lucky I
didn't I didn't plan this before now
it's actually quite okay for white stone
I thought that would be I would be in
trouble but I'm not you know yeah well
okay let's say night a for I can take
even be five and I can take me five
anyway also here 95 d 2 is covering the
b-form porn the question is what is like
doing now yes but i have got Bishop e3 m
amongst others Bishop e3 and Queen
somewhere Queen B 70
Bishop in 327 via night I can go nite c7
maybe yeah maybe this is working 97 f ed
VTR ok this is also also possible still
I've got 97 here but if form yeah before
is hanging at the end so um I must them
I was just tether maybe this was a
really stupid movie should be three yeah
well I need to I need to go
okay so i thought maybe have something
because of his somewhat strange piece
coordination here
I'm down to 40 seconds this is this is
brilliant of course I Bishop b5 yeah
this happens with with 40 seconds on the
clock not sure how it was without this
move I simply have burnt down too much
time by farm
I the position wasn't wasn't so bad of
course I mean probably wide was was very
okay but it doesn't help if you if you
burn so much time
yeah should play d 5 but okay 30 seconds
some helium managed somehow 90 f 6 is a
good move now
check
yeah at least I've got an a pest porn
okay rugae six he can sacrifice I'm back
check
yeah okay this absolute nothing as long
as you have the depot on you can you can
always try a bit too to find some some
tricks but yeah I simply learned how to
much time okay this position is it's
just good for wide it's but it's not so
easy to play to play precisely yeah of
course I can just play Queen B 1
couldn't be to something this this
should be a better for white because his
be five points weaker than might be for
porn I simply have the space advantage
so it's clear that this is better but i
thought i would be directly just just
winning here this material and here this
is tricky this is probably probably not
so good i mean probably it is equal and
it's not bad not bad not bad for me of
course it only was bad for me when I
overlooked we should be five of course
I'm cam it's this is a bit awkward
already with the book on c4 I must them
just plain I d2m lost so much time in
the opening okay thanks for watching